[Musique]
c'est une cabine
qui a été conçue spécifiquement pour
permettre à des milliers de personnes de
réaliser leurs rêves de vol spatial en
toute sécurité
et de maximiser chaque aspect de ce
fabuleux voyage
c'est aussi la pièce maîtresse du design que
quelqu'un a dit un jour  moi, le vaisseau
spatial galactique vierge a été le premier à
être
construit de l'intérieur
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
atterrissage
donc nous avons en fait 16 caméras
dans la cabine et à tout moment au moins
deux de ces
caméras seront  concentré sur chaque
passager
ou membre d'équipage et donc euh pour que les gens
documentent vraiment leur expérience
également dans des déversements et des vidéos haute définition
afin que lorsqu'ils descendent, ils
puissent partager cette
expérience incroyable avec
tu connais des gens sur les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
étrangère